there was a change of pace at this
refugee shelter outside Berlin when a
talk-show host from DWS Arabic service
decided to depart from his usual format
it turned out to be a moving experience
for him I'm a lighting studio we usually
invite guests to the studio but we
wanted to meet refugees where they are
to hear how they're coping and what's on
their minds we want to know what
challenges are facing in everyday life
many of these 550 refugees are from
Syria they endured grueling and
dangerous journeys to Europe before
arriving in Germany they came through
Serbia Macedonia or Kosovo now they say
they can breathe more easily the lodging
and services are very good the only
disadvantage is that it's far away from
Berlin that makes it harder for us to
adjust to life here the refugees have
heard media reports about the attacks on
refugee shelters elsewhere in Germany
but they're not too concerned we're not
afraid we've lived through Syria's
brutal war and escaped the barrel bombs
this is a safe place
nothing's going to happen to us here
after surviving unthinkable Horrors in
Syria these refugees say they're ready
to start afresh they want to learn
German and find work they're hoping for
a brighter future for their families